In our opinion about your university
university of the Basque Country or euskalerriko
University of a.
The university
of the Basque Country is the university
public autonomy,
obviously from the Basque Country
and has 3 campuses,
1 in Guipuzcoa,
1 in Bilbao and another in Vitoria.
You can study practically any career
has 1 incredible academic and technical offer,
from engineering,
passing by right,
psychology,
health sciences,
biochemistry
and there are also many careers that are
duplicated on different campuses
so that you can
study it in the one that catches you closest to home.
It is also 1 university
where you will be able to take your license in Basque.
What do I particularly like about the Basque Country?
This university
is a socially committed university
as well as with the locality,
then they have quite a few projects
of social commitment,
volunteering,
learning, service,
etc.
and also eh well,
I believe that academically and in the insertion
are quite good in the workplace
because they have
many connections with the Colombian ecosystem.
University of the Basque Country,
we adore you